no dejo las armas hace más de dos años
ahora es uno de los ex guerrilleros de
las farc que trabaja hombro a hombro con
los campesinos de guaviare una región en
el sur de colombia
juntos transforman la cosecha en
productos más elaborados
donde hay mermelada y hay también
algunos vinos que están saliendo como el
la salle como el cg que está produciendo
el campesino y además que son orgánicos
y además que son nativos de la amazonía
colombiana este trabajo es parte de su
regreso a la vida civil un proceso que
no ha sido nada fácil desde la firma del
acuerdo de paz han asesinado a más de
250 ex combatientes y muchos como noé
aseguran que el gobierno no está
cumpliendo sus compromisos en la
implementación ha sido muy poca en la
parte agropecuaria en la parte del campo
y también en la parte política para los
gobernantes la historia es otra el
gobierno ha cumplido y la cooperación
internacional está logrando que estas
familias se dediquen a actividades
productivas sostenibles la ayuda
internacional de la que habla es la que
presta la unión europea
del fondo europeo para la paz desde 2016
21 países de la unión europea junto al
reino unido y chile han aportado más de
127 millones de euros unos 154 millones
de dólares todo para respaldar la
implementación del proceso de paz
colombiano uno de los 30 proyectos
financiados es caminemos la iniciativa
en la que están hoy y que es liderada
por francia empezó en el 2018 y vemos
que hay más de 400 proyectos tienen
actividades productivas que quieren
desarrollar puede ser la producción de
pescado o la producción de ovinos de
cacao o de panela además de ayudar a la
reincorporación a la vida civil de los
antiguos guerrilleros la siembra limpia
y sostenible que hacen estas familias
ayuda a proteger el medio ambiente en el
tercer departamento con mayor
deforestación en colombia según el ideam